j'ai dit c'est vrai que maintenant pour
avoir accès à l'argent c'est peut-être
plus compliqué alors non c'est
effectivement tout est bloqué voilà on
est d'accord
alors qu en france c'est donc non tu as
dis non alors oui mais justement on
avait encore vierge
on a découvert entre temps qu'elle avait
d'autres comptent d'ailleurs il peut il
tapait si elle veut mais qu'est ce qu'il
a dit pardon mais plus de voiturier quoi
c'est important qu'ils avaient elle veut
plus donner 10 euros un voiturier ccd
titre enfin il faut rappeler quand même
que dans le couple c'est johnny qui est
extrêmement généreux extrêmement
généreux bon maintenant je sais pas
comment elle va réagir c'est vrai que ça
passe non mais ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que je sais par ses copines qui
lisons ont trouvé qu'elle a retrouvé à
saint barth
effectivement le train de vie a changé
c'est à dire que moins de face et moins
de quai mais il est vrai que là du coup
tout est bloqué donc forcément mais
enfin on va pas permettre la naissance à
les parties à saint barth pour un vol
low cost pachayeva quand même sympa faut
pas déconner quand même
je veux bien les sept locaux à saint
barth los angeles ça va quand même non
oui mais là c'est encore une campagne
pour la réhabiliter auprès du public
parce qu'elle a beaucoup perdu une terre
qui fait la comédie de de la
communication du titien est
extraordinaire je tenais à souligner
alors qu'effectivement moi je suis pas
d'accord avec vous c'est pas pour la
réhabiliter c'est la vérité elle
redevient une femme comme tout le monde
bien sûr le droit elle a le droit avec
preuves car sac à main cinq ou dix mille
euros
demande toi parce qu on nomme savent
quand même une chose est ce que la
presse racle quand même les fonds de
tiroir pour surfer encore sur la radio
ni vrai tout a été dit à mon avis d'ici
un ou deux mois on n'en parle quasiment
plus même plus du tout alors moi je vois
pas du tout où est la plus avancée dans
la salle et ça je veux dire que votre
avis